what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation my God I have had this movie muted on
all my social medias for far too long now so we
could react to it right here and that is of course
Scream Six join of course with John who is rocking
a shirt to my favorite horror movie franchise but
now he's the winner thank you John for being here
and Andrew ready to ruin this movie by constantly
pointing out Easter eggs the whole time and
predicting the killer way too early on how
are you Andrew of course now I'm gonna predict
the wrong killer thanks for putting that kind
of pressure on me I'm good uh ready to watch
stab sick or Scream Six rather and uh already
with the references I know you prep that joke two
weeks ago and he's delivering it today people hey
leave a like stab that like button also
massive thank you to all who have followed
us on our patreon page we've been covering Sony
movie reactions around the channel we've got an
influx of patrons so thank you super sexy rejects
for joining us so as always full length Reaction
watch alongs where you sync up with your own copy
of scream sticks available for super sex Rejects
at our patreon page but we also cover several
things exclusively over there for the reaction
highlights and watch along is included gentlemen
are you ready to do this let's do it I'm ready
are you doing an impression of my uncle Greg
[Music]
hey oh that's Samara Samara weaving
share first victim or our first fake out
uh-oh Reggie so nice to phone meet you in
this incredibly embarrassing way it's very
cool restaurant is it on Hudson yes uh I'm now
walking towards Hudson voice sounds familiar
this is not the first impression I wanted to make
on a college professor it's just film studies so
oh what do you know cinema cinema try teaching
at class on 20th century slashes to a heap of
hun over 19 year olds I love this class sign me
up what's your favorite scary movie not that one
out of those cliches comes an opportunity
for Outsider Art a voice for the voiceless
you might say that's this movie what color
is the outside of the restaurant I I think
it's red I don't see anything red yep it's
definitely red yeah I'm not seeing anything
red here oh you will it'll be on your
dress oh it looks like there's an alley
I can cut through is the restaurant near
an alley what a way to lure ooh scarecrow
he's staring at me what oh [__] he's following
me I don't I don't see anybody oh he's clever yeah
where are you are you oh he's got a knife it's
like a video game voiceover sounds familiar Clash
about slashers and you still walked into a dark
alley yeah that's not funny no it's not oh whoa
holy [__]
[Music]
wow now I see something red as an
angry ghost face clever opening
oh what the hell damn it I uh I can
totally hear it now oh this is a flip yeah
foreign does anyone have eyes
on Parker he's logged in Ned too
oh hey Tara Jason uh do you think we're gonna
come to the okb party we will is your sister
coming oh my God I think Tony River Laurie's the
killer I was gonna say can you guys any ideas
who the Killer is I know I think Tony River
Lori is about to get the boot right now too
The Cult of ghost face
out damn spot why would Luke just throw
the lightsaber over his shoulder [Laughter]
not my Star War I just got massive blue balls
and I had to practice please don't be mad I'm not
dude we said we wouldn't use the voice on
each other turn off the voice modulator
I'm just trying to get the voice right
you got to have your practice I get mine
uh tell me what it felt like all right fine
it was even better yeah Friday the 13th Takes
Manhattan where are we just talking about
she wasn't human anymore I get what you
mean just an animal yeah just meat she was
just meat but she wasn't just meat Jason
she was a person our film Professor ah
I just want you to tell me why you think you're
doing this we're finishing Richie's film that's
right oh cool are you using the cameras yeah the
cameras all right douchebag let's play so strange
he's in the washing machine I'm gonna
hang up now but you're getting warmer
he's behind you taped to your back
oh oh he's dead
armor you're on fire
awesome tank did you feel
like an animal Jason whoa
wow
oh my goodness we have to finish the movie
who gives up about movies yeah we do we give
a flip about movies that is an intriguing hook
it's like multi-level marketing of Ghostface if
you invite five horror fans and they find five
horror fans so how are the new meds treating you
Billy's right next to her this group therapy
but I'm really worried about is you it's how
your sister isn't dealing with whatever happened
to both of you a year ago yeah whatever happens
checks notes murder last year I found out
that my boyfriend was also a serial killer
him and his psycho girlfriend killed a bunch
of people this crazy rumor started online that
I orchestrated the whole thing and framed
them this dude's going to need therapy yeah
Richie was my boyfriend wow but you didn't
could you say that a little louder please
and how how did you stop him I stabbed him
22 times and slit his throat but that's not
why I'm here why are you here Prozac because
it felt right fascinating by law I'm required to
report this to the authority I didn't say I was
going to do anything not explicitly no you know
she even implies she's gonna do it yeah and all
this stuff in the past would have been like it's
already reported yeah yeah there was copster and
everything she should think about Zoom therapy
that's what happens when you go to betterhelp.com
Elm Court clever
[Music]
way being too loud where's Tara she
went to the Omega Kappa beta party um
I've been checking each other out for months why
don't you just talk to him I'm gonna go find Tara
is that that wasn't Frenchy was it no man it's
Adrian uh from Arrow and then the guy in She-Hulk
Mindy
Meeks Martin being at a house party after you
were almost brutally murdered at a house party
no I think of it like being struck by lightning
the odds of it happening twice to the same person
are extremely low haha especially when you're the
killer I got a bottle of Fireball up in my room
wow subtle you want to call it a night I think
that I'm actually still gonna hang but you guys
don't have to wait for me don't worry I'll take
care of it sure you will Tara's good down here
sorry bro I didn't catch up you heard exactly what
he said it's fine I want to yeah see chat it's
okay she wants to come on don't behave like that
though it's gonna tase you in the balls real quick
you're stalking me now oh yeah it's that
psycho girl psycho also a movie reference
have you the rest of my life so you're
just gonna pretend it never happened
you have post-traumatic stress disorder I
was trying to look out for you I know you are
you can't do it for the rest Jesus that is so
messed up I have tissues if you want tissues
I have like three tissues I'll die on the
Mojo I'm going with Ethan as the one of the
killers go back to your dorm I'm pretty
sure the fighting is done for the day um
oh thank you for
uh I think you're really special oh
don't do it guys conflicted don't do it guys
post-traumatic stress disorder
hookup is the best dude
whoa he's secretly Richie's brother
not ready for your sister and your
friends to know that you enjoy
physical contact with another
get up here right now the mutilated bodies
uh Secrets out Jason Carvey and holy [__] that's
that from from getting out of the city what thank
you very much suspicious new game and I think we
got it from here [Laughter] that was great Quinn
before you make the unilateral decision to
abandon my college education and flee the state
I'm calling him now thank you
Gail what
I said afraid I need you
to come down to the station
I would love it if she is the killer I would love
it I think it's smart keeping their attention
the also the Harding and conflict of the
story yes it's really a smart call what
show the world who you really are a liar and a
killer you shouldn't believe everything you read
on the internet yeah Riddler you and Tara better
watch you better watch yours whoa you better watch
dang
I'm lying here girls holy [__]
you got a problem here guys kill him
oh jeez [__] lovely yes I like this
ghost face doesn't care about public places
or anyone who gets in the way
oh damn
oh he's like The Punisher oh this is awesome
I'm here for shotgun ghost face boy
I love how worn down that mask
is too it's got to be from before
that'll work
yeah stealthy they've been making
so much there's enough noise
yeah and grab some groceries on the way out
oh arrest Sam she did it clearly
do either of you have any
besides everyone not anyone who's still alive
thanks FBI's here claiming jurisdiction Sydney
works for the F yes oh hey yes [Music]
she is part of the FBI okay cool Ghost
Face killers of 2011. we're just leaving them
on purpose which means whoever's doing this is
a student of the killers who came before maybe
he believes Sam's the latest in a long line yeah
[Laughter] my bad I did I didn't realize
but I've done this dance before Oh I talked
to Sydney oh she wants more money she sends
her love but she's taking Mark and the kids
someplace safe Patrick Dempsey she deserves
to have her happy ending so that means
she'll be in the next one right [Music]
oh so the victims are not personal they're
targeted specifically to frame you're a day
reading you know you know wow
[Laughter] in the face what a pointless
glass yes watch through it decorative
oh there gotta be a bunch of Easter eggs
in those names I love him he's like a yes
I was waiting for this song can't do a screen
movie without it I don't care what location
you change your damn stream movie too someone is
out to make a sequel stab one took place tomorrow
College suspicious new characters brought in
to round out the suspect list and or body count
check check we're not in a sequel because nobody
just makes sequels anymore we're in a franchise
you can't just stay at the hospital everything is
bigger than last time bigger budget bigger cast
bigger body count no Sydney whatever happened
last time expect the opposite franchises only
Survive by subverting expectations did Ryan
Johnson write this Legacy characters cannon
fodder at this point usually brought back only to
be killed off in some cheap bid for Nostalgia bye
Gail wow main characters are oh boy am I in the
friend group yeah am I like one of the targets
and yes not Evan Peters you are the shy dorky
guy who no one suspects because he's so shy and
okay wait why am I on the suspect list
I suspect them Quinn the [__] roommate
we better that makes it more likely that she's
the Killer because having a [__] dad is a
great cover do you not remember how these movies
work tell it I think it's pretty safe to rule
out the four of us who went through this last
year no no different expectations what if the
trauma you all went through caused one or four
more of you to snap what a smart [__] person
I mean face facts if we're all
suspects you're all suspects
everybody's a suspect including
Kirby so the prime suspect is
this poor woman yeah on the street last night
life of a Survivor there's
also mountains of evidence
Sam if you did it it's okay none of us
can relate to what you are experiencing
and I'm really really sorry that
you have to do that alone oh
there is so much more I like about this movie
than the last one there's so much more I've
all been through some [__] up stuff and
we are coping with it differently I mean
we moved here together for one very specific
reason to wreak havoc on New York [Laughter]
we are the core [Laughter] there we go I've
been sleeping with cute boy from across
so he's the new Jerry O'Connell holy
[__] hey yeah what's up [__]
oh [__] damn Samantha throw
something in the window frustrating
hey not right now I wish I could enjoy this no no
back at it again
oh smart to do that that fake out earlier uh
send her a text send her a text oh oh no run woof
foreign
yes the Butcher Block smash his face in oh
evil dies tonight right here right here
oh
get your hands away from the door
dude this ghost face is
actually scary [__] go hard
you have to come one at a time somebody let's go
Mindy's the killer I feel like it could be yeah
or Chad I mean nope Mindy I go Mindy I'm still
keeping my Ethan pick ing more positive I don't
miss it come on damn there's so much tension
Mindy offering to stay could be sus though and
she wasn't killed she was just hitting the arm
ah I would work on like sliding the door oh this
is so sad but I'd rather
her die than Mindy [Music]
oh I think America's gonna fall
this is giving me home alone vibes
oh no we go she gonna fall oh God goodbye
[Music]
oh this is so scary
oh what a day sure dick face
oh man that is so cruel
oh
man
I love this ghost face yeah he is actually scary
this is hard man's actually scary I breather
I feel like Ghostface hasn't been legitimate
he's scary at all as much as I love this whole
franchise I'm like this guy's actually kind of
terrified [Music] anyone anyone friends not me
not anymore but especially the police don't
trust the FBI but you know live in the moment
where were you when when last night dude
I was in a study hall with a hundred other
people you can ask any of them bring
me on 100 nope I'm so sorry step back
you're at the top of my list damn it I was
wrong it's not him no no it could be still
could be I know but it seems too obvious now
and that's what they do in this franchise
sometimes it's the most obvious sometimes
it's the least obvious ly oh this poor guy
it's giving me shades of Halloween where Sheriff
Becker lost his daughter they took me out of the
case I'm not gonna stop until I find him my family
you die oh quarter mile at a time boy you okay I
came as soon as I heard Dale I swear to God
no truth okay they work together on Friends
reunion we didn't know we needed it's really meta
right now I know where the masks are coming from
Kirby Carol interesting Jason and
Greg were little Atlanta Rich boys
doesn't make sense don't worry I'm
just really good at my job you'll
get there why is she so competitive with a
Kirby Kirby too half your age too what is
it's giving me shades of scream
three it's a shrine Gail here is
giving me shades of all the Scream
movies that came before this one
's faces are giving me all
the shades of every screen
Drew Barrymore Casey Becker hey
hey she's in the movie there you
go they could afford the pictures oh
[__] about the whole God franchise
stab three scripts how much do you
think this could cost these guys
the first one right there yeah
Steve Henry Winkler principal
oh Dewey R.I.P cops like money
and evidence can get lost pretty
easily present company excluded of course
suspects my alibi checks out so I can keep an eye
on you Roomie this poor guy I hope he's the hero
yeah I told you I was just a guy the question
is do you guys think it's one or two though two
damn how [__] cool is this place Papa can
you hear me he's back I hear your horror fan
it's been set best Nightmare on Elm Street the
original and three psycho two is underrated
yes did we just become best friends yup
I think I might have an idea about how to
turn the tables on this creep yeah we're in
sorry Gail no press allowed Police business
my job too but all you suspects in Victor come
with me I got all you covered so we're really
doing the phone tracing thing that never works in
the movies I can trace a call in under 15 seconds
killer usually calls from somewhere nearby
and you think they're safe because it's broad
daylight in a public place this is exactly
how our Uncle Randy died yes exactly yeah
Richie yep why don't you just Trace Richie's
fool yeah I mean that'd be a solid lead it's
a clone of Richie's phone waiting for me
to call desperately hoping I'm nearby so
the police can grab me but I'm not I'm a step
ahead I got a VPN he's on the upper west side
on West 96th how did you know that what Gail
no hello handsome food it's for you may ask
who's calling please I was wondering why there was
never a black ghost face he says it's the Killer
Jesus it's her first phone call right she's never
been called hello Gail I don't understand that
you and I have never spoken on the phone yeah
confirmed don't you know the Legacy characters
are disposable now nobody cares about oh don't
let them walk off doing someone made a buck
reporting your death it never works out for the
[__] and the mask oh cool two killers I'm going
three you couldn't stop what happened to Dewey
just like you're not gonna be able to stop this
get that one yeah you gotta have
a gun Gail yeah Sydney's got a gun
oh yeah pan face
do not fall off the skyscraper please
get to the Panic Room
yeah shit's hard to work
when you're frightened yeah
how's that for nostalgia
best they never have a bulletproof first on
yeah but this is new rules Andrew you missed
sure I did you win I'm in the
elevator heading for the ground floor
or maybe I'm wearing a bulletproof vest
good call can you hold please huh nice
uh you're running out of ammo or that
was smart but she must have shot the
wrong person like Scream 3 where she's star 69s
[Music]
okay oh
gotten worse sometimes worse come on
oh this ghost face is so freaking
oh yeah oh get up cute oh no come on girl
you got this don't go for the knife just
leave look at how beat up that thing is too
mean ah [__] [__] you hey yes yes damn
fast terrible shots I mean you've never gone
to the range there's still a chance too
many times she's been stabbed in her life
I'm just gonna take a little nap right yeah please
out of the way out of the way come
here okay there's there's a chance
there's a chance she's doing a great
job too Sam oh yeah they're both great
I got you as fast as I could and where were
you I don't think it's him they're not doing
love interest two movies in a row that's what
they want you to think she wants to punish me
so maybe I let him I'll just give
myself up if this is what I have
to do yes you have to let us protect you this time
we're a team remember core four isn't there
somewhere like safe we could just hole up in
he's just gonna keep finding us great you
said though hate him did anyone see Home
Alone now you want me to do what we want
to lure him to secure location and travel
cool you should assume there's two killers guys
to the theater more people around you
voice doesn't sound too far from Ghost yeah
really I was just thinking that Michael Myers
that's crazy how they have some Morrow Ravens
character there from Reddit or not I could
see Kirby still helping though yeah I just
gotta throw them all out there any possible
scenario so I could say I was right yeah bet
on all the horses to win one of them will pay
no damn did you see the movie Speed
get on that thing evil dies tonight
[Laughter]
they did the lament configuration
Freddy Krueger how many
stops do we have all of them
that's how many movies there will be this
was like the worst night to go traveling
yeah guys we all float down here
that was really good I believed it for a second
oh he's coming
this is really inventive no
he's on the floor
damn it no not Mindy oh [__]
no ah [__] where's homeboy
somebody helps we gotta get your honey okay
he let her live you're gonna
be okay you're gonna be okay
not you what don't trust anyone remember we don't
know you just like Jerry O'Connell and scream 2.
I cleared the whole place before you got here
it's Kirby weapons one gun and I hold on to it
I am the only one with a badge here
and that's the way it's gonna be
um are there any other entrances or exits you know
you're not safe here whenever someone says we're
safe here it means you're not grab a weapon and
clear this place yourself kill your friends Kirby
yeah like how they have Stu
mocker's jacket right there a
robe oh yeah they got Tatum's outfit
they got all sorts of stuff in here
bro oh no they fired Jeremy
two months ago damn it unstable
she's no longer with the FBI yeah no yeah damn you
Kirby I was right so Kirby and Ethan right no not
Ethan I'm trying to be halfway right here maybe
it's Kirby and the icky guy from the party just
no I mean listen if you want them you have them
you think I want these yeah kind of they're like
100 years old maybe that's your thing I do like
100 year olds I actually well it's about time and
maybe we're seeing how long I wanted to do that
yeah you should have done that a lot sooner I know
we're supposed to do it like
a lot more times we don't die
no no no no no no no
oh nice
let's go Chad let's go let's go come on
come on you could have stomped his head
hey what about that there's an exit door let's
go let's go Bailey's on the way but oh God damn
it yes
or at least in unmasking geez
amateurs
[Music] no oh Chad the best chat that ever chatted
[Applause]
I need you to be ready you ready come on mother
it's okay holy [__] right in you did you kill
Cohen did you kill my daughter Jesus Christ
whatever this is good [Laughter] no yes
I knew it I called it at one point I knew in my
head I was thinking oh three ah I did call that
what mixes I got one right all right sure and his
daughter speaking of family wait for it my name's
not Ethan Landry is it Dad yeah and that's the
that's the daughter the roommate this one I had
a feeling how'd they fake a whole death yeah
it was a good way to get off the suspect list
a little fake blood a prosthetic you'd be amazed
at what a grieving father can get away with jeez
oh interesting that's two the sleeves your fathers
ah oh boy I'm gonna need you to put it on join us
I didn't commit those murders in Woodsboro
it wasn't me well we know that of course
you didn't what do you think this is based on
some [__] conspiracy theory who do you think
started the rumors about in the first place dang
it's not enough to just kill someone these days
you have to assassinate their character
first true when Dad here discovers your
horribly mutilated body he'll say
some poor dumb bastard right on
the internet that you're the real
ghost face it's the perfect alibi
you're a killer just like your father no I'm not
yes you are you mother mother or you killed our
brother Ah that's what I got his phone Richie
so the whole family is really unstable yeah
runs in the franchise family Richie
I had a feeling it wasn't until I saw that
photograph of what you'd actually done to
him that I knew then I knew you had to die you
had to be punished along with anyone else who
stands in our way he's uh like Nancy Loomis
the Dead real great parenting job by the way
oh what are the stab killers in the back they're
the same all the time yeah we're all crazy
Kirby's gonna save them that's why
I helped him build this collection
I built a tribute to my son which is why this
is where you have to die Sam Now put on the mask
he was
that an insult it's like Sydney
insulting Billy he was a strong
funeral young man he was a lymph a little
[__] who cried before I slit his throat
oh yeah
ow recognize this [Music] oh sorry oh my
God I need this that's insensitive what
are you gonna do about it [__] oh yep
yep yep yeah become your father enjoy it
accept your destiny yes this is holster
up yo this chick got so hot in this movie
whatever your mom already so funny
he's just having a good time now not
scary but so far it's your last
scene go nuts do what you want
where's her boyfriend
oh let me go no now let it go Sam no don't kill
her off no not her so just break another ankle
oh give her the knife
land on his face yes
oh she's enjoying it she's
enjoyed it she's enjoyed it oh wow
ouch
fine old girl oh she's enjoying
it looks like you're down another
oh
boy looks like you're down
to another child [Laughter]
oh oh Gail where are you [Applause]
why did he charge him
no sense [Laughter] he was in the moment of
Revenge he wasn't thinking logically [Music]
Scream one yes good reference I
understood that one hello Detective
um Black Swan laughs all right I'm a police
officer how do you think this is gonna go Sam
who do you think they're gonna believe huh what do
you want for me probably the one who's still alive
no no yes oh yeah look at her go wow everywhere
what the [__] are you doing you're not a Loomis
this is a really bad look for the both of us
was a murderer you mean
you're not gonna kill this one
oh no no do something that warrants it I
learned all you do it all the places to
stab without killing I love that look do
it come on oh you did with our family so
word good nice meta to the end if they wanted
to go super meta they should have had Dennis
Quaid play Richie's dead two two meta and
then we're gonna check on Kirby yeah she's
fine she said a bunch of stabs she's been there
before done that thank you for letting me go
I know you could take care of yourself you too I
don't trust you with a drunk guy but two killers
you're good it's called a character Arc oh final
girls [Applause] oh yeah yeah Kirby she's the TV
[__] I saw that in a scary movie once so did we
she's talking about Scream one nightmare
numbers three three right all the above
we're all part of the same
and Legacy doesn't always have to be a bad thing
the Disney sequels were okay
it's fine just to be average
Chad survived like do we
yeah I'll take it he's like I'm the new Dewey
before
and then he died because he
took off his office [Laughter]
[Music]
yep yep it's okay there will be a scream seven
yeah but she's really enjoying killing
she had a lot to the mask she held onto
the mess didn't she oh no no no no no no
no no oh she took it as a souvenir no no
Sam Embrace who you are Sam
yeah [__] that's evidence
dies tonight
ah the Big Apple
cool
I hear there's a post credit scene yes oh wow
oh they didn't write it I thought they wrote it
so it's the same directors as the last one nice
my basic summary of you I hated it we know we know
no that's not what I was going to say were you
here this whole time Andrew no she produced it
no wonder she lives okay she couldn't throw a
brighter painting to death Campbell my basic
summary is I actually like this way more than
the last one agreed however I like the motive
and the reveal of The Killers more
in the last one but other than that
I thought this was a much better film overall yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I I the only thing I heard
about this was that there was a big divide with
the with the reveal of who the Killer is and like
annoyed people that was the only thing I heard
I heard from like a lot of uh you go on Twitter
and be like that's why I said like mute like a
mother because I was like just remove everything
and then uh that's all I heard that I did not
obviously know who it was but uh Roger Jackson
yeah I don't think it's that upsetting is it no
I I mean like the actual circumstance that they
should be related to Richie like that I don't know
I have no idea why people were upset like I don't
mind it there has to be some kind of connective
tissue and that makes sense especially going with
you know really riding on the new characters
and all that stuff you know committing to the
new characters but I like the idea a lot if they
are doing like a secret origin of the next Mexico
phase yeah this whole time that's what they've
been doing Corey Cunningham do it if like Sam
is really gonna be the one I love that idea
I understood that reference by the way do you
know I isn't uh the guy who played uh uh you know
virgin guy isn't he freaking fighter and Avatar
I mean maybe you're right you're usually right
about those things why that didn't look like him
boy howdy Courtney Cox can stop billing
she's the EP okay she gets that role yeah but
I feel like I don't know Melissa Barrera earned
that no Sam I really I really felt like this one
did become its own movie they did their own thing
they did weren't like I understand the last
one was so much about the commentary on being
a recall and all that yeah but at the same time
I felt that commentary kind of hindered some of
the effect whereas this they really I really
cared about all the characters I didn't want
any of them to die yeah except for like the
random people I didn't really give a [__]
like that the core four they want the core four
to die there's a lot of great twists and turns
throughout and there's a lot of style I like that
a lot I think you pointed out too many times like
this is one of the scariest if not these scary
well I guess three ghost faces but I mean when
we were watching Ghostface like operate throughout
the film like and you really felt the tension in
each scene not that you didn't in the other films
but like this ghost face was absolutely Relentless
and you could feel the anger seeping through so
when that actual reveal does happen you know all
I it is very similar to Scream 2 with Nancy Loomis
getting revenge on her on her son with Billy and
all that but again you just feel the intensity of
this ghost face so much more I feel like in this
film but I think the thing I love the most in this
yes the core four but the relationship between Sam
and Tara it was so much more fleshed out in this
film and they just did such a great job with those
two characters I've loved every scene that they
were that they interacted in and I remembered
maybe you felt the same way about me we weren't
huge fans like I would love Tara on the last one
but we weren't huge fans of Sam in the last one
yeah I thought she was excellent here like yeah
beginning to end I thought she was excellent your
your best line was she's really hot in this movie
well I mean the whole thing comes together because
yeah just the last movie didn't feel like there
was something about it that didn't feel like it
flattered her performance very well whereas here I
feel like they really made sure to like let her to
shoot her better and also just let her command the
screen like I thought the in between scenes where
you are just doing character stuff were better
handled in this movie by far than the previous one
yeah because the previous one I felt like was held
back by a bit of a bit too much reverence and and
this one it was at a weird Crossroads yeah because
because you know you have to please the purists
whereas this is less you know it's less necessary
for this to do that but yeah I thought just the
believability of her expression her relationship
with Tara like yeah and their relationship is
the core for like even the stuff with her being
overprotective could have been cliche and annoying
but I thought they handled that in a very nuanced
way and and yeah she like whereas in the previous
movie I felt bad being like man you know there's
something about her that isn't working like this
one she yeah was like the center figure I liked
the most yeah yeah I thought she was I think she
might have been my favorite character in her too
yeah totally and like even if she does ascend
to being the new ghost face as as odd as that
might be I love that choice though like I won't
be here to watch it yeah I think that would be so
cool my favorite character was Courtney Cox's
boyfriend yeah he was great he yeah he was he
was he was the Crux of this film he showed up man
if he hadn't been there she might have died true
well I at these directors whose names I constantly
forget but John will know radio silence that's not
their names it's their group name shut up shut
up not every movie needs a post-credit scene
yes it does who does the brand you have to
keep the bread that reminded me a little of
Spider-Man homecoming with Captain America saying
you waited this long for something of disappoint
whatever it was I think it's it it's like Tyler
Gilpin and Matt bettinelli open or something
like that yeah radio silence is what they go by
that sounds correct I would like to re-watch it
to see some stuff that I wonder if lines up like
there's three killers and none of them look that
tall but they all except for dermit Maroney yeah
but every time his face never looks short every
time they were killing they were super tall you
know you all have platform boots yeah I wasn't
sure how this film was going to play out in terms
of this is obviously our first film without Nev
Campbell Sydney of course and I didn't think
this film was hindered in any way without her
obviously of course it's you do most just seeing
the character of Sydney of course she's just she's
a Legacy character she is the star of the other
films although you can make an argumentary wasn't
the star of the last film because she was barely
in it but I this is one of my favorite scream
films so I was pleasantly surprised that even with
the absence of Nev Campbell of course I would have
loved to have seen her in this even if it was a
cameo role I was pleasantly surprised that even
without her because I was a very big concern
coming into this film but I didn't think the
the storyline suffered in any way it was nice to
obviously get a little shout out uh from her with
Gail of course but I thought the the storyline
was again the Crux of the storyline for me that
got me emotionally invested was Tara and uh Sam I
just I really like the way they fleshed out those
characters and all their interactions and like you
said you just really gave a [__] about all these
characters to the point you didn't want anything
to happen that's those are good horror films to
me when you can make sure obviously we want the
jump scares we want the the graphic violence of
course but when you can't give a [__] about
the characters and you don't want anything to
happen that's those are the best kind of horror
films for me yeah there's a solid installment
great use of Music throughout and I think these
directors who've worked I loved and ready or not
this felt like oh yeah they made this movie yeah
I understand it's got all that punch in wit it's
way more gory than the other ones there's like
poppy gory people said it was like more violent
and yeah no it definitely is way more violent
yeah I like disturbingly violent at times but
it was always fun to me I thought I thought it
was a lot of fun and and I was relieved to be
like yeah this ghost face is like the Terminator
you know he is non-stop brutal and it has his
eyes on a Target and there wasn't just a bunch of
like jokey prat fall stuff it doesn't feel like
they have the meta angle here as you would want
from a Scream movie but the meta quality isn't
as front and center as prior installments yes yes
it was more of like a like if there was something
that felt like personally brutal about it you
know like they had the thing that would help
have a construct around your film but it wasn't
about the meta thing they were clever to make
the meta thing like a really vital aspect of
just how do we figure our way out what can
we use about these movies and not rely on it
for much of any humor because I feel like in
the past we might have done a lot of both yeah
whereas this is pretty much them kind of we we
know that beat and I thought they they yeah made
it sort of an intense sort of thing each time when
they did touch on the tropes of the movies
um I'm not I really wish they handled though
I think there's something about the way they did
the reveal reveal and this was now like there is
some there is something about it that I don't I
don't mind the decision I really don't mind that
this it's a little far-fetched like I think that
the strip with Quinn very far-fetched the fact
like how faking the daughters like that one very
far you've got a witness across the window there
like yeah that isn't that's a little that part is
a little much two-thirds of that I'm totally okay
with sure but Quinn being alive was like uh I
don't know man that's a lot for me to wrap my
head and the moment I wasn't really thinking about
it because I was so was caught up in like what the
reveals are well they they show you a lot whereas
I feel like I may be putting it too off screen
would clue Us in but I feel like if they maybe
didn't give you so much to go off in that and
more played it from the outside room perspective
we gotta have like a corner you gotta have an
autopsy he said he switched the bodies that right
is that what he said or something like that and he
passed it off it's like there's a lot you could
do as a cop but I'm like yeah that's a pretty
that's a tall order there's a lot of people now
you're in like some weird Saw movie territory at
that point I mean there were there were shades of
Saw throughout this and I think smartly to bring
in a more direct like police angle I was like okay
seven and other other police throw does that make
sense but at the end it did remind me of a Saw
movies twist ending well I know the cliche with
I felt like this movie was really doing its own
thing until they got to the reveal of the killers
and then they all started behaving leaving like
there's something about I don't know why they they
always everyone becomes stew Billy and Stu were
the perfect ones the perfect reveal and the right
level and then they they kind of made a decision
like every movie following this they all have to
be and I thought I thought Jack Quaid actually hit
a really good level and experience when it came to
the reveal I thought he hit a perfect level and
then Derma Mulroney was like what the hell just
happened with terminal take it away [Music] he's
so comical so cartoony yeah I like to watch him
have fun but it does transcend into a much wackier
movie it was very it went too wacky it didn't hit
the tone of the rest of the film where yeah you
got to strike that it's not easy but you do got to
strike that balance whereas as you just mentioned
Billy and Stu like it fit perfectly with that film
and then in other films they've just taken it
a step too far yeah I did like the motif with
um and and the commentary on the here and now
about how like it's very easy to go online
in places like that and just into the public
conversation and twist and warp people's lives
and cast images that people run away with like
yeah it's like so much of the context for them
was great but it it it it just felt like yeah so
many so many like wacky hillbilly movies by the
end I don't I don't hate it so I I might have I
might I might not like it more if I didn't hear
that there were some people who really hated it
you know and so that prepared me for I might hate
what comes up but I don't hate it and I think
what they did with Kirby was smart that was
because they did restrain her for compare and they
and they Justified it within the character of why
she would be more restrained and not you know
like the uh Plucky teenager who says yeah and
I think the the performance was so intentional so
that way you could suspect her because I was told
that it was her like I I did get sold on it and
then I saw the run time and I was like maybe it's
on her yeah wow and I don't know I mean the second
they gave her that like suspicious walk-off in the
second yeah it's like oh no her trap I'm like it
can't be you just can't and uh yeah like I I wish
almost that there had been a little bit more for
her to do that's because there were times where I
was like the Kirby's not as involved in this like
she seemed like she was here kind of to be a red
herring in a way as instead of being like a fully
ingrained member see I don't feel like I feel like
they know how to use Gale and they knew how to
use Dewey but I didn't I feel like they really
didn't know what to do with Sydney in the last
one as much as I love seeing Nev Campbell yeah
um I felt like they didn't really know I felt like
she was kind of forced in the movie she went for a
run in the movie well it makes sense because yeah
she's gonna be like so used to this that she's not
even gonna be involved in the plot probably and I
think they made that choice for Kirby specifically
because like I think that's where they come at
a Crossroads again is uh you know you you see
Kirby's back and you kind of want a little bit of
the flare of what you remember about Kirby and you
kind of get none of that about her other than the
fact that it's Hayden Panettiere again and and you
also get an interesting kernel in that they use
that like oh her life's really spiraled off the
tracks and she's not even been on the force for
a couple months and I was like I don't know like
at least in the resolve maybe we could have had
some emotional payoff because this is a character
people are excited to see a return a fan favorite
from scream for I agree they did restrain her but
we did get that one scene with her and Mindy where
they were having their little yeah I was like
that's the Kirby we know but I mean understand
I did like though how they uh what they did with
Sam and Tara in regards to you know from Sydney's
perspective in terms of Scream 2 after this ordeal
that she had just gone through in terms of the
trust issues and in terms of the trauma that she
uh has to deal with you have Tara with I just
want to move on with my life and then you have
Sam this celebrity that everyone you know ostrates
whenever they see her in public so I thought that
was really interesting choice of making giving
both of those characters traits of Sydney from
Scream 2 so I thought that was a really wise
decision for both their characters yeah and I
think these last couple movies especially with
I mean Sydney so much about her character too
was someone who was ostracized by society as
well as during certain moments of her life and
then sort of watching the way Sam is being has
been ostracized as well and watching her morph
has been fun and that's why I'm I'd actually be
kind of on board for her being like a killer the
next one you were thinking because they they did
continue off of the heels of the last one where
she did enjoy killing the I don't know I don't
want to see a third Arc of her being like I'm not
gonna be much you know like I can't watch that
three times it would be different if they did
that because we've never seen the heroes become
that I think that would be so cool that would be
different well and there was something they did in
the prologue that made me think of that because as
much as like it might be a meme for this movie
to have turned into like oh there's a bunch of
them there's a cult like having the two copycats
at the beginning who are your kind of stock screen
characters but who are now taking this game out
of the personal and into a more broad-scoping
thing I was like is this going to be a ghost
face killing people who weren't involved with
the ghost face Legacy who are like disrespecting
it somehow so like I feel like you could almost
warp it in on itself that way with her where
she has some kind of motive that isn't just
pure evil I got another question about that
sure yeah sure yeah yeah some stuff is really
starting to [__] me a little bit nitpicks in
order I don't know if it's an epic man I'm just
I'm anticipating comments in order for this in
order for this plant to have hatched and worked
he they would have needed to move to specifically
New York City where he is the cop yes the head of
like the police department it's not hard to
get a transfer to a specific police station
did he say he transferred I don't know maybe
not that I recall we're looking too deep into
this I agree with you no no I agree with you I
agree with you yeah I mean like I could buy them
being obsessed in enough to have found their
way there but to to set up a career as a cop
in the amount of time that would take or to
translate it seems like it would be a lot you
bought this whole place under the name of the
rich people and built this whole Shrine and the
I'm like it seems like they've been established
like they grew up here they're established where
is she from Modesto they say that he is from
Modesto in uh no he is not from Modesto he like
him and Amber hatched that plan he is not from
Modesto no way so they really planted the seeds
there from like but this guy had to be a in law
enforcement and he also got the Kate oh I mean
I don't know I just assume he could bug or
track her phone or whatever but but but yes
having it be so clean that he is a New York cop
in the last what six months that they've lived
here if they didn't already live here either
begs a huge coincidence or just some kind of
weird explanation that we didn't get I mean yeah
I mean like the two the children make sense that
you could just transfer them in yeah like okay I
I understand that yeah that's a psychotic family
right never underestimate Revenge um yeah man
yeah that was that that was fun but overall it
was a very fun movie with some Great Kills and
I think uh I love the sound design on this movie
with headphones was very rewarding shotguns
and knife skills yeah they have some great
sound design here and some fantastic editing
as well and I thought they embraced like their
cinematography their style like the the sleekness
yet the ickiness of it I thought was perfect you
know I I thought they might do a little bit more
like New York [__] oh yeah but they did enough
for me that wasn't like about like watch New York
settings you know but like the convenience store
uh the subway station uh the the subway train
I thought had a lot of great tension to it yeah
because you're going between high buildings and
things yeah there I thought they did enough uh
we don't need a Times Square and So Meta to show
Jason Takes Manhattan of course yeah and they're
in New York and we were literally just talking
about that before we started filming I mean that
is that is a requirement that they include like
if they didn't include a very obvious Easter egg
I feel like people would have right I knew this
is Super Fresh because we just watched this but
any idea where you would rank this in your
scream rankings are too too early too yeah
above three are you sure is that like not ranking
above Mission Impossible too sure uh I mean it's
definitely above three and five I would agree
with that I don't know if I would need to watch
it it's got a fight with four yeah in the middle
yeah one and two still Reigns Superior I might
like four more than two now I use them fighting
words I used to it used to be an easy like one
two four for me but then when I re-watched four
is good when I rewatch The Scream movies last year
um I was like oh [__] you know I might prefer
four yeah four was underrated it was a little
ahead of its time yeah I agree um yeah I like I
like four a lot uh so I was especially excited
to see like yeah I think there's some fantastic
sequences before but man that caught this the
scene in the and uh when they have to escape
over when they're in the police car and they
have to climb over him in part two oh that's one
of the greatest tension moments like it's not so
scary when you re-watch it because you know
it's completely yeah first time you watched
it that was a scary [__] I've ever seen yeah
I did also like that sequence where they're on
the subway and the the lights are just going in
and out in the strobe light I thought that was a
really cool sequence as well yeah like this really
I thought there was more even though like they
take the city to bigger and while you have some
some new characters like they they have the joke
about the core four but I really felt like this
movie really focused I thought they really focus
in hard on their character then really knew how to
do it was in the last movie ever kind of sometimes
forget about them um well and you have to keep
track of who all them are yeah like this was like
Tara insane this was Sam's this is a salmon terror
story they're the heart of it and them having to
you know grow together and I I what I liked too
was that they they paid attention to the fact
that they are all of them are trauma survivors of
the situation and I thought it was really smart of
them from a character standpoint to be like look
we all survived together but yeah none of us can
understand what you're like when Tara is talking
with her like none of us can actually understand
what you're going through because this is you're
getting this on a whole other level than yeah than
us you know and that must be so not only that but
it's I felt like I agree with everything you just
said but I also feel like it's not only that that
you're getting on a different level but you're
also the daughter of Pilkey Loomis so that's
something also that none of us can relate to
as well exactly so you're factoring all that and
where she has her own identity struggle because
um you know it's like you have there's like
several forms of PTSD and you know like like
one form of what is the uh I forget the actual
terminology but there's like a PTSD version where
it's like yeah you experience it like the way
Tara laid it out I thought was interesting to hear
I'm not gonna let these three days to find my
life like oh [__] that was just three days
huh but but that's like okay a PTSD situation
that you definitely got to work on but then you
have like levels of like complex PTSD where [__]
you you've like grew up with it and you've had to
endure it and she it's like lifestyle things and
that's more of what Sam has had to deal with on
top of the actual you know killings and [__]
as well being inflicted her way uh so she has
a whole new kind of psychological Journey she has
to go through because I've not I've never been a
big fan of this whole like skeet old Rich showing
up [__] because it just messes with my logic of
how does she know like how he would talk and sound
like and whatever and and it I I have a hard time
buying into it because it's like he behaved
so much like he did she watches she watched
Scream one okay too much stab one yeah just
replace that actor's face let's get over it yeah
like videos about how he behaved as a killer
she watched some Roman's videos but I'm not
saying that anything's gonna come about it but
I thought it was an interesting reference to
mention uh stu-macher because again originally
he was supposed to be in Scream 3 and then I I
could be wrong let me know in the comment
section I believe because of the Columbine
shooting that happened around that same time
they kind of asked the idea of having him so
you're right I'm curious if that anything
comes about that because they were asking
in the film if I remember correctly like where is
he what's going on so he lives who lives one and
all these character things just real quick
like as much as it seems like blasphemy not
to have nav Campbell I thought that it actually
kind of served the movie not to have to to find
something for Sydney Prescott to do don't
force her in here yeah and I thought that
let everybody shine and then Gail is just
the right amount of here and as your main
Legacy character and then did you know the scream
tropes enough though when you're like oh okay okay
the second the EMT
I actually did think before the film started
I was anticipating like that was the Legacy
character well she was the only real
Legacy character oh besides uh Kirby
but I thought she was gonna not on the
heels running out of [__] for Gail to
do it is the same [__] every time you got
a boyfriend she got a boyfriend in this one
she's just like oh Gail you disappoint me
by going back to being a a freaking snake
journalist and and oh she's gonna go off
the Record now and start helping out yeah
every time with her yes it can you know she
should be the wipe away character it is the
same thing like every single movie second
movie it's been the same thing no I mean no
no no no no no no it's the character yeah as
someone who like loves friends like friends
with my all-time probably my favorite
it's my favorite comedy show of all time
um who loves friends and knows like Monica Geller
so well it's it is crazy to me to be like I only
see Gail weathers when I watch this franchise
like I'm not like I could see like Matthew
Perry or something with the group Chandler I
could think yeah but then when it comes to her
here I'm like oh yeah I just see Gail weathers
and I think she embodies this character and I
love the presence of her and I was I would be
I was gonna be like heartbroken to see her ago
at the same time I'm like you got to come up
with a different way to introduce her yeah
I I agree with you I mean they could have
played off too even though they they did go
into it a little bit just how she's dealing
with you know the death of doing again they
did go into it I'm not saying they didn't
but just play a little bit even more into
that I I do I gotta interrupt I love the way
that phone call with her was handled because
when when Dewey like you were saying was brought
up you know and you see her getting emotionally
triggered by that and coming to tears on it but
then she has to find that resilience again to
like power through the situation I'm like
oh that actually feel like that was one of
my favorite as much as I'm making fun of like
they just keep introducing her the same way in
all these movies that was one of my all-time
favorite Gale scenes sure I think the point I
was I agree with you but I think the point I was
trying to make is instead of just doing the same
thing over the could have played even more into
that because I did love that moment as well just
a little more is all I'm saying as opposed to
just doing the same thing like I'm gonna write
a book again and that's all I'm saying but uh I
think my biggest issue with this movie is they
didn't do Dennis Quaid uh as Richie's father I
think that would have been the ultra medicine
see really really he's a hardcore Republican
oh damn it so Oh I thought it was rain I
thought it was Randy no I'm pretty sure
the Quaid family or the jack is all right
it's a different movie at the end and it's not
like a mind-blowing motive but he's still fun
to watch it he is he is I was gonna say I think
Jack Quaid's gonna change his last name to Ryan
for obvious reasons but yeah yeah I thought the
I mean the kills the kills being more brutal
reflected the motive of it being more personal so
I think that that in itself works I thought the
I just I just thought it was kind of I thought
it was pretty inventive what they as much as I
I wasn't as in love with Scream five as a lot
of other people were I thought the motive was
like oh that's pretty smart how they lay that
out yeah and I didn't feel like any of this
was like oh that's close okay we've got a lot of
shades of screen too in this from Nancy loomis's
revenge for Billy so for sure that Personal Touch
of Revenge absolutely I think I would come around
to that thing you said earlier though for me is
like yeah I prefer most of this but I do think
the original movie has a clever more clever like
chassis underneath the car yeah you know but uh
yeah but if this movie at the same time doesn't
feel like it's a ever a Crossroads with itself
at a really allowed them to just get to know the
characters they invented for this franchise and
and let them become their own and like I loved I
I love I thought they were all great I thought I
thought all of them were great yeah I would
be happy to see all of them return I would
look forward to these new characters scream
seven torch past scream seven the core four
yeah yeah how are they gonna warp the
title next time um yeah all right guys
well uh for me I guess I would give this
like uh I give this like a solid six steps
yeah those kids those stabs were brutal yeah
are you sure this movie's already yeah director
commentaries it's the first thing to come out is
this stab scene was 40 and we whacked it down to
three it's still so pulpy though sure it's still
so I I was under the impression the way people
talked about the violence that it would be just
like Rob Zombie a little silence or just like I
don't enjoy this this isn't Fun violence like to
me they still to me the violence was still fun I
still I still thought the violence was like still
heightened and pulpy enough and just like just
ah this is fun yeah just the right amount of fun
and then that New York City just like they hit
the ground running and it's nasty but it never
loses that you know pulp I think that is the
thing about New York City that does resonate
over here is the aggression of New York City so
like the vibe yeah that that registers over here
more than like going to like they were fighting
Statue of Liberty Liberty we're a Times Square
rooting we're getting a hot dog they either should
have done that or had Ghostface punch someone's
head off just clean off with his fist yes oh that
would have been awesome yeah all right guys well
this was a a really fun movie I would probably
give it like uh like my first viewing I'm like a
89 oh that's good what is it that is damn that
is that's a great score I would give it like nah
I bump it to 90. I'll give it like a nine right I
really enjoy I really enjoyed this would you give
what would you give Scream one just curious
oh scream one's like a hundred percent excuse
me like a 65 I don't I don't think there's I was
just curious what the bro I don't think I have a
single flaw first for screen one ice cream one is
my favorite horror movie of all time I I I I love
that movie and every time I decide to re-watch it
it's great it just gets better and it becomes like
my favorite one film class study of why this
movie works so much and that and enough none
none of the movies in this franchise have taught
the the last hour of the first one sure the last
half hour the first one all let's do Stu's party
night is so it's so perfectly constructive yes
yeah and iconic yeah like that whole thing it's
a lot of people forget like that that's like a
whole like 30 to 40 minutes sequence that's all
just taking place at on Stu's party at night you
know and it just builds it oh it's perfect and
that movie too was like such a Splash In terms
I remember people at the time when I was too
young to see it being like this actually really
Disturbed this feels like real crime yeah for
the time very grounded not Supernatural yep
oh yeah yeah that was the real mentals I mean
yeah the the commentary here is like the meta
commentary here is not is nowhere near as clever
as I mean I I appreciated the meta commentary and
I thought what they wanted to do with the granite
commentary and the fifth one was really was good
at least the the intention a lot and there
were some there's a lot of cleverness in The
Meta commentary here was really just about them
explaining why they can do different things yeah
really riffing on like you know like I thought
they were gonna Riff on you know like now they
were doing this you know reboot we got it
they're gonna be more yeah yeah we're gonna
ignore details from the past it's only a sequel
just two yeah yeah all right guys we'll leave
your thoughts down below Andrew thanks for being
here you're welcome thanks for having me thanks
for not stabbing me Nancy Loomis and uh Scream
2 and uh John thanks for being me sure and uh
John uh say hi to Greg hi Greg and uh hey thanks
for uh checking us out Flex oh foreign [Music]